mientras 24 el momento de conocer cuáles
son las principales noticias en materia
económica en américa latina y también
por supuesto en el resto del mundo y es
por eso que nos acompaña como siempre
daniel hablando muy buenas noches
daniela vamos a empezar con noticias de
américa latina no juramento nuevo de
presidente de perú pedro castillo con
promesas económicas hola santiago qué
tal pues mire pedro castillo tomó
posesión como nuevo mandatario de los
peruanos y aunque su elección asustó a
los inversionistas y a los más ricos
temerosos de sus planes para una nueva
constitución les aseguró este miércoles
que no había el más remoto plan para
nacionalizar la industria en cambio dijo
que buscaría un nuevo pacto con
inversionistas para respetar la
propiedad privada también quiere reglas
claras para los mineros en este que es
el segundo mayor productor de cobre del
mundo y en donde esta industria
representa casi el 10 por ciento del pib
y el 60 por ciento de las exportaciones
en campaña pedro castillo había
mencionado que podría aumentar los
impuestos a los mineros para financiar
reformas de salud
educación justamente santiago otra de
sus promesas es duplicar el presupuesto
de este último sector y crear un
ministerio de ciencia y tecnología y la
pandemia bueno sigue metiéndose en las
compañías no grandes empresas comienzan
a exigir vacunas sí señor el gigante
estadounidense google advirtió a sus más
de 130.000 empleados en todo el mundo
que si quieren volver a las oficinas en
octubre tienen la obligación de
vacunarse contra el kobe de 19 también
lo hizo en netflix ya varios gobiernos
locales y entidades públicas de este
país han acudido a la exigencia de
inmunizaciones pero google es la primera
gran empresa que hace lo propio esto ha
aumentado o ha alimentado más bien el
debate sobre si existe una base legal
para exigir vacunación para volver a
trabajar hace unos días del alcalde de
nueva york bill de blasio hizo esta
sugerencia a las compañías y un juez
federal confirmó la semana pasada que
una universidad puede exigir vacunas a
sus estudiantes lo que de alguna manera
pues refuerza la balsa ilegal para
establecer esa polémica obligatoriedad
la noticia de américa latina' vamos
y habrá sino porque el gigante
sudamericano vuelve a tener un
ministerio de trabajo bueno lo hizo el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro quien volvió
a crear esta cartera ministerial y
nombró como su jefe al diputado onyx
lorenzoni a quien le encargó
específicamente lidiar con el desempleo
que alcanzó un récord de 14 a 7 por
ciento en abrir el ministerio de trabajo
y seguridad social data de 1930 y había
sido disuelto por bolsonaro el primer
día de su mandato es decir el primero de
enero de 2019 en ese momento fue
incorporado a la cartera de economía en
medio de un esfuerzo por reducir el
aparato estatal haremos ahora danny de
la semana de resultados financieros a
nivel empresarial
santiago siguen conociéndose los
informes del segundo trimestre de 2021
con unas empresas que les va mejor que a
otras desde luego a medida que se van
recuperando de la pandemia veamos el
gigante de comidas mcdonald's multiplicó
por cuatro sus ganancias en el segundo
trimestre hasta los 2.200 millones de
dólares
puede ver crecer sus ventas en un 40 por
ciento en el sector automotriz el
fabricante estadounidense ford
sorprendió con ganancias a pesar de las
clases de chips aunque si bajaron casi a
la mitad frente al mismo período del año
pasado mientras que el japonés nissan
pasó de perder a ganar y por eso no se
puede hacer comparación porcentual
finalmente la estatal mexicana de
petróleos pemex dio una muy buena
noticia tuvo utilidad de 719 millones de
dólares en el trimestre haremos ahora de
los indicadores de la jornada que nos
dicen el street del cerro mixto después
de que la reserva federal restará
preocupación a la variante delta del
coronavirus lo que inyectó tranquilidad
a los mercados facebook él le dio un
impulso tengo el tecnológico nasdaq tras
revelar que duplicó sus ganancias en el
primer semestre y américa latina cerró
en positivo con las bolsas de méxico y
argentina subiendo más del 1 por ciento
utilizamos con la cifra del día como
siempre mide 6.500 millones de dólares
santiago en esto se valorizó la
aplicación de aprendizaje de idiomas
lincoln después de que sus acciones
subieran casi un 40% en su debut en
nasdaq en la bolsa de nueva york este
miércoles esta empresa se convirtió en
la más reciente startup de tecnología
educativa en impresionar a los
inversionistas de wall steet veremos
cómo le va queremos dar y ablandar
muchísimas gracias por esta completísima
crónica de economía nuestra audiencia y
le invitamos a continuar informándose en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]
y